did you see what happened to the nfl
with jack del rio's comment he made
about january 6 and he talked did you
hear this on the question so anyway so
this guy makes a comment i want to read
this to you and and and share with you
why this is uh at the same time with
page seven if you want to go to page
seven
so uh papa papa where's it at there we
go nfl hall of famer ed reed urges con
commanders players this is washington
commanders players to take stand over
jack del rio's comments um
this is a bleacher report story pro
football hall of famer ed reed wants to
see washington commanders players speak
out against jack del rio for the
comments he made about january 6
insurrection at the capitol retweeted
saturday that the hundred thousand
dollar fine del rio was assessed is
nothing and player coaches by him need
to put your pants on and stand up to the
59 year old del rio initially caused the
stare
uh on monday when he responded to a
tweet about the hearing on the
insurrection in which he seemed to
equate the attack on the capital with
the public protest that occurred in the
summer of 2020 in response to
minneapolis police officer derek chauvin
murdering george floyd commanders head
coach ron rivera announced friday that
he got fined a hundred thousand dollars
after two met discussed this okay the
money will be donated to united states
capitol police memorial fund fine okay
so
making that comparison
is a bad comparison to make
how many businesses were shut down
because of january 6
how many communities were turned upside
down with fire
africa i saw what this one man a grown
man in his 70s is saying why are you
doing this to me this is my business why
are you doing this to me i've been here
for 50 years
i can't afford to why are you doing this
to your own community what happened to
that uh protesting are we seeing
anything on that where's the hearing is
anybody being held accountable so so let
me tell you folks if now you're watching
and you're saying well pat you know
do you understand what january 6 i said
no no no no hang on remember
valuable currency is the ability to
reason
and to be able to reason we have to try
to control
our emotions which is very very hard to
do you just heard michael transparent
vulnerable saying i can't even look at
the man's face because it's so much
emotion involved when this thing
directly impacts your life
but you cannot tell me you're a
hypocrite if you're willing to hold
january 6 people accountable but you
don't want to hold the people
accountable that affected more people's
lives
that affected more people's lives
negatively the blm protesting and the
founder of blm what happens to two years
later she's sitting on these three
houses really oh so that's what you
support it no that's not what i support
it but that is what you support it but
that is what we drove
but that is what you were doing no but
that's not what i'm talking about no but
that's exactly what happened so
accountability needs to be held on both
sides absolutely if you're doing it on
both sides then we'll sit there and
we'll say what okay cool this is fine
did you see what happened with geico the
lady got a suit geico for five point two
million dollars and guys who have to pay
this out have you seen the story oh
first of all you gotta cover this on the
soft stocks money so this is perfect
story for you so type in geico 5.2
million dollars std
okay
geico
may have to pay 5.2 million dollars to a
woman who got an std in an uninsured car
what she had sex go to usa today's story
not the npr go back and go to the usa
today just type back and type in usa
today usa today watch this so this lady
there it is okay
geico ordered to pay 5.2 million dollars
to woman contracted std during sex in an
un in an in short vehicle
let me get this straight
you had sex in an in a car
you got std from this guy can you zoom
in kai so we can read it as well because
kai is more interested in the article he
forgot about us so
in geico has to pay them 5.2 million
dollars
remington has to pay somebody 72 million
dollars because another person chose to
use the gun and remington has to pay 72
million dollars
geico is going to have to pay 5.2
million because this woman sexually
transmitted disease in the insured
vehicle of her then boyfriend a state
appeal court ruled on tuesday the misery
court of appeals western district
published an opinion in favor of the
woman identified as uh m.o who alleged
that she contracted hpv during a sexual
encounter in short vehicles in 2017.
shouldn't they sue the boyfriend then
what that what the hell are we talking
about here
what are we talking who's winning today
nobody who's no it's not it's not nobody
is whose argument is getting attention
today
this gets attention so we pay 5.2
million really oh and then what happened
to the streets all the riots no no no
they were doing they were just being
peaceful protesting no we had nikki
fried here and jedediah called her it
was all over twitter because she says
well
you know jedidiah's like florida doesn't
have a problem with peaceful protesting
she says yeah peaceful protesting says
what are the kind of protesting is there
do you remember that moment what are the
kind of protesting is there i mean
should we be able to do protesting where
we vandalize and we're okay with that so
so no that's okay so again the more and
more michael my opinion the more and
more they do what they do the more their
hypocrisy
is revealed and the more people sit
there and say i kind of supported that
but i don't support that it's kind of
weird like okay you know you go to uh uh
trump and his daughter
his daughter comes out and says what did
you read the story or no uh uh said she
agreed with bill barr's yeah
so she said it's on page six she says
um she says on page six let me go to so
ivanka trump says she believed a.g bard
that her father lost 2020 election this
is bloomberg ivanka trump the daughter
of donald trump a former white house
advisor said she accepted that there is
no evidence of fraud and that her father
had lost 2020 election a clip-over
testimony was played during the white
house hearing on january 6 on the
capitol she was asking that position
that impression what impression she had
when the attorney general william barr
and trump and his advisors there was uh
no such fraud it affected my perspective
she said i respect attorney general barr
so i accepted what he was saying now
she's not saying yes or no she's just
saying i respected the guy so i what i
uh uh uh
respect what he's saying trump comes
back and says she wasn't involved at
that time okay
do you sit there and you agree with
everything trump does is right no no
absolutely not do you sit there and say
what everything everybody does is right
no but people have to start
reasoning again
the ability to reason has to become a
very valuable currency again
we've lost that recently
we can sit there and have a friendly
debate and you can say i agree with you
i disagree with you cool got it walk
away iran this was great awesome we
reasoned
you won you made a good point i'm like
i'm smarter now i made a point like
that's a good point i didn't think about
that but we're not doing that anymore so
i think the people who are able to
reason
are going to come out
as leaders mcconaughey when he gave that
speech it's not the most popular speech
to give
you know a lot of people from nra is
like dude what are you talking about i
can't believe you said this
they don't like that speech but guess
what it did they got a couple of guys to
say
listen let's talk background check let's
do this listen reasonable yeah he's re
he's given a reasonable speech saying i
learned how to shoot a shotgun
in uvalde i grew up and they taught me
how to shoot in that city
i know like i'm all about this but i'm
not about this
and then we have to sit there and say ah
this [ __ ] just made a very good
argument
ah okay all right good point fine
got it
at dinner this last week saturday with
two uh
big hollywood actors and we're having
dinner and i said you know where my
position changed when it came down to
health insurance health care what what
what what was it john q
you ever seen the movie john q with
denzel washington was kind of like this
kid's trying to get a heart
at this point of the game listen man we
got to figure right away for this kid to
go it's quarter million dollars
am i saying let me pay for all your
abortions because you decide to have
unprotected sex i'm not for that but in
that case we're like the kid couldn't
get that and we learned so much about
our system
do we just let this person die
did we just let this person go so but
that was a way where we watched we said
good argument i'm for so i think those
who reason will lead the future of
america that's why i hope so i'll tell
you when it comes to january 6 look i
believe in peaceful protest if it's not
a peaceful protest it's not a protest
then it's vandalism whatever else it's
you call it what it is
my problem with this is that it's it's a
hypocritic
hearing
it's all one-sided they have one goal in
mind and that's to bury trump and it's
it's hypocrisy and i just can't support
that
no i don't believe in it don't get me
wrong they shouldn't have done that it
was wrong whatever trump probably said
things to incite them even though it
wasn't direct but you know the flip side
of the coin where was the capitol police
where's the national guard that he
authorized to be there
nancy pelosi is a hypocrite so it's hard
for me to support anything that she
wants to do because i know it's in her
mind it's not for the benefit of people
she doesn't care nothing was going to
happen to her
you know it's the same like you know
with the supreme court if this was you
know this if this was a liberal supreme
court justice this would have been on
the front page of every newspaper would
be talked about you know the right would
be in blame they'd use it to high heaven
and i just can't stand that i i you just
i can't stand it and and again patrick
this is coming from a guy that lived
that was 20 years
a bad guy a criminal i mean i call it
the way it is you know
i just cannot i can't but do you think
they should not have these hearings
not at this point in time
when this country is reeling you know
when people are going to a gas station
put seven gallons of gas in their car in
california and paying 60
it's just over a quarter of a tank for
most people that's what you're worried
about january 6th at this point in time
when you know patrick named all the
things that people are struggling for i
mean look i live out in cal i live in a
pretty affluent neighborhood
you know um
yeah newport beach but you know i see
what's going outside of that
i mean this is the time to have these
hearings are you that worried about
trump maybe that he's going to run
against so you want to bury him that's
the whole motivation for this so for me
it's just too much hypocrisy to support
and again i don't believe that they
should have stormed the capital 100 i
don't believe that at all but i don't
believe what they're doing is real and
when you have a different motivation you
you lose me on that
by the way by the way is is there
anybody more far left on tv than rachel
maddow she's probably got to be up there
ryan okay so she here's what she said
rachel maddow admits that trump had
nothing to do with the capital breach
she said i don't know if you saw this
clip or not i didn't yeah she said msmc
rachel maddow who inspires barbers
around
she said this emphatically reminded the
fellow panelists and audience that
donald trump's rally was not repeat not
the starting point of the so-called
january 6th insurrection here's her
words just a key point that yes there
was a pro-trump rally at which the
president spoke and we can absolutely
talk about all the things the president
said there but the idea that the rally
is the thing that got
out of hand and that somehow resulted in
the breaching of the capital that rally
was very far from the capital and the
people who as you say did the initial
breach that allowed everybody else to
come in they never even went to the
rally
and this is rachel rachel meadow that's
shocking we're not talking about
tucker you're not talking about hannity
right you're not talking about
santorum you're not you're talking about
you talk about madame shocking rachel
maddow if there's a list of who is the
most hated person the person she hates
the most in her life
trump's on the top of that leader's
bulletin yeah he's competing for the
number one spot so
if but but you know what this gives me
this validates the point of even rachel
maddow's being forced to reason
she's cornered to reason because her
audience is saying i'm sick of your [ __ ]
i believed you you're pandering
start reasoning with me that's why i
tune in to you or else your eyeballs are
going away i'm not watching you anymore
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]